hello everyone how are you guys doing
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
just finished recording the outro of my
last episode so going to go ahead and
start this one we uh we have 134 Mill in
the bank at the start of this episode
and we're going to see what we can do
right now so really no plans I think I'm
going to go finish my gargoyle task
right now also do a herb run if you guys
don't know how the herbs work in my bank
I've kind of gone over this a couple
times but what I did originally I bought
90 ranar seeds I have some planted now
and about 38 left and I just build up to
see how many rars we can get so on a
pretty good grind right now going to go
do that finish off a gar task and then
we'll get this underway nice and easy
got the feud Quest done it's going to
give us some thieving XP I just got to
kind of get my thieving up just for
General quests so that's what I've been
working on going to go do some pyramid
plunder now I believe maybe some more
quests I don't know really and first
little bit of postc com for the episode
so I don't know what I don't know what I
was up to my room is probably just
chilling the room and I'm grinding out
some quests so uh barrels gloves is a
huge achievement for the account any
account and one problem that I have is
doing them too late in the account like
doing the quests when whenever I'm
already like 99 of a stat and I have 93
uh strength at the moment so quite close
to that but it's something I need to
kind of get out of the way sooner I also
um on this account I want to go ahead
and get more of the achievement Diaries
done because I feel like they're very
helpful in a ton of scenarios and the
one thing holding back me back on my
main was questing so right there if you
guys missed that that was a third H
plate legs merge for about 2.2 mil and
then I made a ton of money on these
odium Wards and Abyssal dagger so that
was really nice up to 107 mil there in
the inventory plus an odium Shard as you
guys saw there so uh yeah went ahead and
finish off anaca lament that's a quest
that I haven't even done in my main I
don't think so that's that's exactly
what I'm talking about I know for sure I
haven't done spirits of ID Quest on my
main so there is another example uh I
mean it's just like Quest and I just we
have a we have a up and down
relationship I hate doing quests but as
soon as I start doing them it is so much
fun and I love just rattling one out
after another so right there went ahead
and got 60 mining it was actually doing
three tick coal which was uh or iron I
think yeah three tick iron which was
pretty interesting first time ever doing
that uh finished off lunar diplomacy and
from there went and trading some AFK
Mage and got a dust battle staff which I
thought was a little weird to be
honest there we go finished off a little
bit of magic so I got up to 74 almost at
75 realistically 75 is what I'm really
here for because at 75 I'll be able to
do firewave and I also kind of want to
do to string jewelry which I think might
be 80 so we're working on that right now
this is just a really nice way if you
guys don't know to AFK and train magic
you just come here with whatever your
highest fire spell is and just AFK on
some dust devils it does require 65
Slayer but it's really relaxed and uh
yeah definitely enjoyed my time there
I'll be back here in a little bit but I
think today I'm going to try to do some
quests I think and as you guys know I
definitely have to uh merch eclectics I
love it I bought 60 mil worth of
eclectics I sold on these as you guys
can see right there I'll go ahead and
show you guys the profit that I made on
that so I bought them for 10.9 sold them
for 11 .35 so pretty much made like 400k
is off of that going to go ahead and buy
an Eclectic right now and see what I'd
be able to sell them on for hopefully I
made money on this which would be really
nice but yeah so 3608 don't know how
much of a margin that is so I bought all
of these for
3567 which would mean that we would make
about 40 GP on all of them giving us a
total of 680k or so which is really nice
and just like that all of the eclectics
have sold on so we going to go ahead
find some more Mars and time to merch
them out again but as you guys can see
turned 60.6 mil into
61.3 nice little bit of money made there
but uh yeah I'm going to work on that
again and this is another Quest done so
just finished off rum deal two Quest
points Got The Holy wrench I don't think
I get any levels from this but
definitely good quest to get done and uh
closing and on Barrow's gloves slowly
but surely and here we go this should be
50 smithing so just finish off that
going to go ahead and do cabin fever I
think now so there we go working on M
just went ahead and did a Cod iwan merch
though while I was afking so went ahead
and made 800k off of that also as you
guys can see here went ahead and got 75
range I guess we've had that no I just
got that almost 76 and 87 HP on that run
as well and there we go shades of Morton
Quest done so that's a cool three Quest
points um puts us up to
186 I had a clue scroll that required I
think an eight of M so I decided I'd go
ahead and do a lot of the quests that
are over in this area so going to go
ahead and do I think in search of my
wreck right now here we are again with
some postc com so just finishing up a
Quest real quick so that was ins search
m I have a hard clue and that's what
made me kind of go on this grind of
morania area quest which I will hope to
finish I don't think I have on my main
and there's some quests along there that
I haven't done and I'm really interested
in doing so from there I went on ahead
and finish the Last Quest that I had to
do before I could do I think desert
treasure which was uh in search of oh
wait it was it had it's like the iov
quest I don't even know but I finished
off Cav fever this was huge all right
I'll talk to you guys in the next clip
about this but this was a massive merch
for the account I made about 13 mil on
it so here we go all right what is going
on guys just woke up had a crazy merch
last night overnight so as you guys can
see I bought one Dragon Hunter crossbow
down here for 24 mil three more up here
for 24 mil which in total is 96 and I
knew that they would go back up
overnight because I kind of noticed a
trend with the new items they dip down
right before Night hits and then they
Skyrocket overnight so put in an offer
to sell them all for 27.3 that's almost
what they Peak debt so that was really
good and sold them all off for 109 mil
which was a 13 mil profit all right
haunted mine can [__] off this Quest was
terrible I was so happy to get this done
I mean it was just God awful but I ended
up merching off some arcanes while I did
the quest made 1.3 mil in total which
was really nice and I was really happy
about that no doubt at all back again
for the first time in a little while so
I'm going to warn you right now nothing
big don't get excited but made a little
bit of money that's that's all that
matters you know small small baby steps
so 200k off the Elder mall we made 400 K
off the Arcane prior Scrolls and down
here they're really separated so it's
hard to see but last night I was buying
Ferro scepter for 7320 charged them and
sold them on for
7449 so I was making about 130k they do
take a really long time to buy and sell
though so I think I end up making like
1.2 to 1.3 mil on that so all together
with all this I mean close to 2 milish
so that's what we've been up to right
now 101 mil cash de if you see here in
my inventory but also but yeah if we go
on over to the bank as you guys can see
we definitely have some other stuff
chilling in here so full derck Fury
Berserker ring so I mean that's all like
8 n milish and then other stuff I'm sure
we have a decent amount of money we'll
see at the end of the video though
haven't made a clip in a while but I
went ahead and did a lot of herur I
guess not a lot it was only like 2,000
potions but it got me a ton of levels I
think I went from somewhere around like
44 to 46 all the way up until 59
probably going to get 60 at some point
but right now I'm going to go ahead and
do some thieving I have to get 52 I
believe for Desert treasure 52 or 53 I
don't I can't remember which one it was
53 it is so once I get that I think also
I have to do is Desert treasure and then
maybe one other Quest and I can finish
recipe for disaster I mean I barely have
even started it but I can do all of it I
guess is what I what I mean to say and
the first start that I need so went
ahead and got 45 thieving and now I can
do blackjacking so this should be a
little faster from here on out and just
like that another merch done so went
ahead bought the code Ian for 72.7 mil
or sold it for that bought it for 71.5
so made 1.1 to 1.2 mil there which is
really nice another merch quite like
last night so if you guys look I sold
off a bunch of Ferro sors for 7 mil 300K
I bought most of them for 7112 which
means I made about 100 I'd say if we
average these two about 120k I started
on both of them so I made about 180k in
total off of all of these so that comes
out to I don't know somewhere somewhere
around two to three milish so definitely
got the cash going up right there 124
mil but I did have to sell on a uh Fury
to go ahead and be able to buy all that
stuff so it's early in the morning going
to go ahead and see if we can find any
merch today and probably end off the
video here in a little bit also I guess
I haven't said anything about my
thieving level I've gotten that up to 51
we'll get it up to 53 and probably do
desert treasure today but that may be at
the start of the next episode just a
random little cooking level [__] kill
me God damn it bro so pissed you guys
don't even know I hate that this of the
video is probably going to come to an
end I was hoping to get my [__] fire
cap cuz you guys know I had a Jad Tas I
haven't done it in a while so I haven't
said a whole lot about it but we had a
Jad task and oh I was on Wave like 55 or
something 53 and I just like I have food
but I just got comboed the [__] out I
didn't even get like comboed really I
just was being dumb um I had I had the
180 safe spotted say like 180s right
here I was shooting him but the ranger
was like way back here and there's no
way I can get to the ranger without
running through him and I didn't want to
do that cuz the Mage is still on me so
I'm like all right I'm just going to
take this out I was at like 50 health
and then he just kept hitting me down
and I was just like reluctant to drink
because I'm a [__] idiot but yeah he
just like he hit me for like an 11 then
another 11 I didn't think I don't I
don't know I'm a [__] idiot I'm going
to go get another task I hate myself but
[__] me I mean I'm just pissed because I
wanted that kill I just want the chance
at a pet I didn't want to do this task
like I much rather would have just died
but I convinced myself to do it and the
fact that I convinced myself to do it
then died is what just annoys me to the
core I'm not I'm not doing spiritual
creatures I'm canceling this task
forever that's one of the nice things
about me finally doing quests is I can
block tasks so yeah never doing
spiritual creatures I don't even know if
I what I have to check out what the odds
of getting certain tasks are because I
would just block turoths too no point to
them black demons we'll do those I'm
fine with that but we're going to go end
off this video real quick so let me go
to the GE we'll get the price of this
bank and we will be good to go actually
could probably just do it here be a
little change of scenery for the outro
finally regain my composure I don't hate
myself as much but but here we are we
finished it off I have nothing in the GE
other than an arum's Hood which is like
50k I mean probably more than that like
maybe 100 but doesn't matter I'm going
to scroll you guys through the bank real
quick obviously most of our cash is in
coins right now what the [__] does that
even mean but there are some things I do
have to stock up on like cannonballs I
used to have 17K which I made up in my
own money so I have to buy those back
and also the eclectics that I was
talking about before I probably made off
merching eclectics about 2.5k worth of
eclectic like not worth of eclectics but
25,000 eclectics is how much like I've
made merching them so I'm going to get
those back out we'll do the clue Scrolls
eventually just not right now I kind of
want to work on getting a lot of
efficient like teleports and stuff like
that and start doing Diaries so that'll
be put on the back burner for a little
bit but as you guys can see I mean this
is like the main stuff outside of the
cash I would guess but there is like s
some stray stuff like a ton of prayer
potions ton of super restores all this
Quest stuff man I got to I got to
reorganize my bank this looks disgusting
uh a lot of ranar uh weeds little bit in
the tab you know just from random stuff
some just average Slayer loot I mean at
this level I'm not getting anything too
impressive yet and then yeah just clue
tabs and it it's just a whole it's just
a whole [__] ton of [__] so it's really
hard to calculate this but that's why we
have the conduit client not a
sponsorship or anything I just like
using them for this particular reason OS
budd's better outside of this but going
to go ahead what the hell I'm going to
go ahead and just press show yeah it
does say 170 options so I don't we're
going to do show value I'm going to pull
this over for you guys real quick so
there we go that should be about
right and we're going to do calculate
Bank offer or Bank total 157 mil so
that's insane I don't I don't even know
what we started this episode with but
that has to be a ton of progress because
I know we've had some crazy
real no plans right now uh I think when
I start off the next video for you guys
if you guys are wondering I'm probably
going to go ahead get my thieving up do
DT then do recipe for disaster I should
have barels gloves next video God I hope
I don't procrastinate that anymore but
that'll be it for me this episode so
hope you guys enjoyed the video If you
guys did make sure to leave a like I
think I'm going to start uploading these
more and more just because I put so much
time into each episode that I want to
show more stuff for you guys and I feel
like you guys will probably enjoy it a
lot more too just by having more content
and more stuff to see so if you guys are
looking forward to that make sure to let
me know if you guys enjoy my content
make sure to hit the sub button like the
video everything shows a ton of support
and I love it with that being said hope
you guys have a wonderful day and peace